we might be drunk
we might be drunk
as long as we are hanging out you know
we might be drunk raise a glass let's
talk [ __ ] head peeps wrecks and a bit
maybe drunk
we might be drunk
yeah
yo
happy new year we love you guys thank
you for listening
uh dude happy new year hey happy new
2022 here we are came out of nowhere oh
god this is crazy i know we lost so much
time with the pandem and i hate losing
time we're both scared of death
you know so so we're opening
well i'm just saying it's it's a looming
fear just waiting there it is the sickle
just coming down on us
that's our answer to death is creating
yeah i think about that a lot like you
do so many late night sets i was like oh
that dude's scared of death oh he wants
a catalog yes i want a cannon
what is a cannon
you ever heard cannon yeah sure about
the cannon yeah the the is it the body
what is it what's the original cannon a
catalog
is there i guess catalog is what you
sell coats out of
you know or a west elm catalog you don't
have a west elm cannon
is there a difference what do we got a
general law rule principle criterion
which
a clay but also a collection of sacred
yeah i think it's both
biblical canon all right all right good
to know we're doing a little we don't
have the beer jew this week we're doing
a little terramanna and soda it's a new
year we want to start light mm-hmm
tequila soda though you can't go wrong
with a little fruit in there it's nice
we're out of lime i wish we had one i
wanted a lime a lime goes a long way
like you ever
do a shot of tequila and you hit that
lime and you go
i'm completely cured isn't that crazy
for dead bodies do they in the war
they'd use limes
lime juice is that am i wrong you're
thinking of lime l-y-m-e that's a
different lime that's how they bury
people lyme disease
lime and limes are very different do
they not use
yeah i'm a real [ __ ] idiot for saying
that right now well i've only seen it in
in like here's another one mustard gas
real mustard
that's dijon baby
i think they use lying to kill smells
though am i that [ __ ] dumb that i
just said that is there lime and
smelling salt what's in a smelling salt
but wait oh we're still on the lime
thing does limes
kill smells oh wait a minute controlling
odors from pets and livestock i don't
know about the dead bodies though
huh i might have overstepped here i
think it's you're thinking of lime yeah
let's pour that on the graves
um yeah but lime it does something it
did something about like that tequila
shot where you're like oh my god i know
it's it helps you it's nothing works all
the time except limes and chapstick
chapstick works man you put this on your
minutes it's a minute yeah but it's like
coke
for more it's like it's like you feel
like a degenerate gambler asking for a
loan yeah that's right that's what
chapstick is chap's like a short money
you know it'll get you by but it ain't
lasting you're better off investing
that's why i never use it
i don't own one chapstick my girl all
day is just boop boop you don't own one
no i don't want it i got one right here
you see you're gonna rely on it
uh what i got another oh you got burt's
bees and chapstick by the way anthony
burt's bees for coming in on that
monopoly and trying to make its own way
because they they came in chapstick had
the market cornered it's like kleenex
when you talk about tissues and you're
like kleenex you're like that's a brand
that's a brand band-aid that's another
one
they're good that's a name for that give
that a goog what's the name of that term
where you have the brand and they take
over sharpies another one give me a
sharpie
i think highlighter might be one too but
i'm gonna highlight one too i might be
overstepping
there's a name for that term
oh
41 bit but what's it called yeah xerox
taser google
generator google's a big one big one i'm
gonna google that wow they [ __ ] yeah
that's crazy no one says i'm going to
yahoo that generously says i'm going to
ask jeeves that yeah you got that right
generous genericization
i might say i might be saying that wrong
genericization
looks right all right what about um and
do you have any uh new year's
resolutions mark ah i never do them
never i feel like if you got a thing
just do it because if you if you talk
about it and at a party here's my
resolute you're not really going to do
it fair enough you're all talk but this
is a podcast true
good point
nothing that you want to change
uh all right here's one all right i uh
when the when the covet hit the gym my
gym closed and i just stopped i would
just go to the gym twice a week it was
like part of my life the the the rec
center yeah sam really yeah yeah the
recson is the best deal in new york yeah
it's like 80 bucks a year you get the
ping-pong you get the shower you get the
basketball you get the weight room the
swimming pool the swimming's what i
would do i mean it's you and a bunch of
geriatrics but [ __ ] it
you also feel like a badass
geriatrics in better shape than
me i there used to always be i used to a
bit about this but there should always
be a woman on a noodle and you just have
to swim around her and you're like this
is the dumbest setup for through your
exercise there's so many asian dudes
there yeah
swim yeah they swim and they pong yeah
asians dominated they're like black of
nba
asian pong yeah i've seen forrest gump
so what about uh so you just stop going
to the gym don't you why don't you just
get a regular gym membership well
i got i got fond i got i got a
i grew up a love for the wreck i helped
the old guy you know some old guy in
dress socks was like
let me help you there sig freed or
whatever his name is it's always some
guy like merman
it's always some old guy duncan you know
so i go hey let me help you anyways
thanks sonny let me buy an egg cream or
whatever
mark saved bernie sanders at the rec
center
yeah yeah yeah still don't have health
care but uh that should be a resolution
oh that's pretty good can we i think
that should be the resolution that mark
has to get health insurance well take it
out of the patreon
i don't think i need i i've been to the
hospital since 88. this is the hospital
it's it's like it's it's more of a just
in case that you should get it mark
you're making a lot of money it's really
it's
it should be one of the it should be
like an agent or a manager it's that's
the thing you just have but don't you
feel like if you don't go to the
hospital you wasted that month
i mean
do you not go to the doctor for anything
you've told me you had shoulder stuff i
mean what do you do you just paint a
pocket i know a guy i know a guy this is
how he's gonna mark i've got prostate
cancer you should see a doctor i've got
a guy he meets me in an alley he gives
me a shot meet me this chipotle bathroom
i'll look at your prostate
[Laughter]
he knows the code this guy's pro
uh yeah all right maybe you're right get
health care because when you go without
insurance hey they look at you sideways
sure they go hey what's your insurance
like i don't have it they go jesus
christ
and then it's like
four grand
yeah dude that's like what health
insurance costs for the year you should
do
you should get it yeah am i wrong here
maybe i'm holding out look at matt is
also saying you should get it i keep
hearing the health there's on the way
it's coming it's coming
free health care
i don't think it's coming oh all right
all right if obamacare didn't push it
through to free nothing is going to push
it through i mean that's
we're
it's not going to be free i mean
american healthcare [ __ ] blows but
you got to get it yeah it's really
horrible but
i'm not doing a great sales pitch here
it's the worst i sound like i'm talking
about game of thrones it's terrible you
gotta watch
right right
well the thing about obamacare is i
signed up and then they had one one
hiccup with the password and i just said
[ __ ] it i'm done you might be because
you did that netflix special you might
be eligible for
sag uh
i gotta pay those dues
oh yeah me too oh jeez i'll just pay him
when i get a pardon something yeah don't
they remind you mm-hmm those unions
remind you i know unions man they're not
[ __ ] around they're not [ __ ]
around and then you forget to pay it
then five years later they're like oh yo
uh 10 grand like jesus christ i have a
gym in my building i don't it's a small
one but i don't use it a lot what oh you
occasionally but i'll tell you this i
got a trainer because of my neck so i
was like i don't use her a ton but i use
her to kind of get back into it and it's
a whole thing in my building it's a lot
of old people and they're kind of like
you're not allowed to use a trainer so
i've been scolded a couple times
first off i'm gonna say this about my
building i get woken up every day by
construction some old [ __ ] is getting
uh you know renovations going on in
there yep you know it's not enough
though it's this [ __ ] this is a peeve of
mine and look i'm gonna i'm gonna start
with saying this is a real first world
complaint but guess what we're living in
the first world baby
hell yeah here's what happens i'm in
there with a trainer and two separate
old guys walk over to me and go
we don't care personally but you're not
supposed to have a trainer what but but
we don't care so mom's a word but you
just say you know cause you're younger
cause they're in the building just
because they don't some weird thing
where buildings are you're not supposed
to have trainers what the [ __ ] how
exclusive is that i can't bring a gal in
to work out with uh she's literally
guiding me because i mean
she doesn't want me to get re-injured uh
so it's like that's literally why she's
there and we're very quiet but they were
like it is a people who go i don't care
personally but this is the rule i'm like
well listen nerd i didn't read the the
handbook here yeah that's why i don't
know the [ __ ] rules i'm breaking the
rules without even knowing them i hate
these nerds and they're all on the board
hey we're on the board and the new york
thing the co-op board co-op board is a
menace you're if you're on a co-op board
you're a [ __ ] nerd you're worse than
the clan
yes it's a whole different kind of group
it's exclusive to new york only in new
york where they're like we have to
approve you yes yes [ __ ] get over
yourself i know we have a board in my
building and they're a nightmare because
we we had to rent out the roof for stuff
because the roof is common space so like
hey we're gonna have a barbecue and like
uh all right well we're gonna charge you
this much it's gotta be over by eleven
i'm like what is this russia we're
having a barbecue get out of here it's
open air no one is up here
it's really crazy um
it's like that's a new york thing yeah
and the nicer the building the country
of the board
yeah anyone who's involved with that
[ __ ] it's like uh just get over yourself
i know get a life go do something go
help go to a soup kitchen what are you
hassling the people who live here for
yeah well they were they were definitely
annoyed with me they were definitely
like
we don't mind i'm like i think you mind
that's a big peeve yeah
i'm okay with it but just so you know
the rules that's get out of here get out
of here i know exactly what you're doing
it's passive aggressive it's phony it's
bad
yeah
you should do that hey
i don't mind your toupee but i heard
some people talking about it you know
like where does it end
yeah so
what does the trainer do is she she's
just kind of guiding me to like
strengthening my my neck again because i
you know i've
you know i have a herniated disc but i
mean do you do pull downs or yeah
whatever we can but she's just making
sure my neck is in the proper position
because i could re-injure it easily does
she hold it did she give you a brace
i'm worried she's getting a free ride
here how much you paying this gal that's
we'll talk about all right all right
this girl's got the sweetest gig in the
world watch the neck okay now do another
one what's the neck well she's also
she's strengthening you know she's
strengthening the muscles surrounding it
you got to know about the body you got
to know the anatomy all right all right
all right yeah yeah i feel like hey she
hands you a pillow and an ice pack and
an apple juice
i don't know if it's a real gig but i'm
not there she does lunchables too
all right all right teddy gramps
teddy grahams were kind of underrated oh
i love teddy grahams dude and you know i
[ __ ] with cinnamon teddy grams oh
i was a chocolate band but i'm with you
oh really chocolate the other one was
honey right oh yeah
where are the flavors pull up the
flavors wasn't there a blue box too was
that original
maybe the gravy was good yeah yeah those
were golden no that's a different thing
golden grahams is a cereal those were
good honey grams oh teddy there he is
dude i was in 7-eleven by the comedy
seller the other day and they sold
vanilla frosted dunkaroos damn for my
money i don't think it got any better no
that's the way to go cause look we all
have a pop-tart but they're too big
that's the way to get some frosting and
it's just a bite-sized version look at
this [ __ ] they they went woke with teddy
grams now he's gotta be holding up a
[ __ ] butterfly what the [ __ ] happened
it used to just be a gram now he's gonna
be saving nature yeah he looks like a
lunesta ad over here
teddy graham come on it's sugar it's
drugs don't don't [ __ ] around teddy he's
got erectile dysfunction
what the hell happened to him do we have
him on the screen are we showing him god
damn it daddy got anxiety wait go to the
old ones
you know they should have like
hydrogenated oil or whatever [ __ ] gave
you cancer
we were eating cancer as kids honey that
was a big one yeah what are the other
ones he was gay back then apparently
he's got the half shirt on the belly
shirt
can you see this on the audience let's
see this look at that
[ __ ]
like jesus christ he's got a little hat
on he's got a ball gag and a butt plug
all right we're going medieval on
teddy's ass what what other flavors were
back in the day these are the new ones
what the hell is this nabisco the
[ __ ] you know it's an evil nabisco is
definitely one of those companies that
was trying to give women like breast
formula
you know
like you gotta have uh breast milk
formula right right
oh yeah i don't know i don't remember
the old one they've brainwashed me
i can't remember woke uh woke up teddy
graham teddy grams is a great like woke
candy people is it you should be just
the trix rabbit lucky charms uh you know
the the what's the pillsbury doughboy
he's connected
he's lucky charms not like offensive to
the irish now is that where we're at
don't get there the irish don't give a
[ __ ]
which is nice yeah there's irish coffee
i beat you like a redheaded shot irish
goodbye they're fine with it the best
goodbye
great goodbye they have all the goodbyes
i've never regretted an irish goodbye no
good point i mean we had derosa on i
remember he literally yelled at me twice
for leaving his birthday in like a
drunken blackout like [ __ ] you you're a
shitty friend three in the morning on
like a tuesday or monday yeah and you're
just kind of like this is what the irish
goodbye is for
it's to save me because he doesn't
remember doing it anyway be like i don't
want to you just want to get out yeah
well the problem with the get out is
they go no stay one more shot and you're
just avoiding that it's not that i like
dislike you or i'm trying of course it's
just the fact that you get me a headlock
and you go come on you [ __ ] stay
another hour and you're like dude it's
five
let me get too old that friend's like
this is a bad time once you hit like
once you have friends who are like 40
and up they should not be asking you to
take another shot that's a those are
some problematic friends and we're
already like teetering on blackout let's
just enjoy the buzz but i mean who am i
talking to i'm i like to keep it going
i do too but i want that next day now
man oh yeah
yeah that's one thing you learn it's uh
enjoy the buzz and just go home remember
were you a fruit roll-up or fruit by the
foot guy
um i mean i was a fruit roll-up but my
parents wouldn't buy any of that [ __ ] i
had to like mooch it like i would have
to go to friends houses yes yeah my
parents will get that [ __ ] either i
loved it i know you go to friends
pantries it was like the scene in pulp
fiction when they opened the box with
the glow i was like oh my god dunkaroos
roll ups uh gushers gushers oh my gosh
we'd have a gusher in my home the
closest you ta are you coming to take in
one on the face as a child just shoot a
hot load of uh juice right over your
chin
that's true that explosion was that was
serious oh man you really felt the gush
oh it was so they were so good oh yeah
that shit's poor we must have been
eating poison who knows what that was
all that [ __ ]
all that stuff was bad
the cereal was bad the lunch was bad
like goldfish i'm sure goldfish is just
goldfish is so good i know cheddar
goldfish anyone leaves anything that
leaves a cake in your teeth like that
though is bad i know yeah
get it out there it's just a gooey
paste
every disease comes through the gums and
we're literally just walking around with
[ __ ] mushed in our mouth and you're like
hey what does my breath stink oh yeah i
ate a a
by the way that paper bag too goldfish
was really trying to be high-end for a
while pepperidge farms yeah yeah milano
it's like you're like just [ __ ] give
me a
no
chips ahoy was never putting on airs
good point coming in a sack yes the
keebler elf kept it real
but yeah peppers raw milano the other
one with the chessmen the chessmen yes
that so it had a rook on it yeah it was
the rook of the night i don't know might
have been the night pull that pull ups
and the pepper
i think it's the night they can go
diagonal
chess men cookie they were good cookies
maybe that's the bishop oh those butter
cookies dude oh god yeah it was the
night all right oh was it all the pieces
i guess it was all of them i only had
the night
what what would the other big peppage
farm i mean dude those uh milano
sausalito cookies what's that pull those
up man
you know i don't care for we'll get to
this later because this might start a
debate but uh the tates
what are those tates you'd seen them oh
yeah they're fine oh those are great
that is that's one of the better cookies
in the in the uh market there put those
in the microwave for 20 seconds you get
yourself a glass of milk my friend you
got yourself an evening yeah
that's like free basin i mean it's too
good you're flying close to the sun with
that [ __ ] farmhouse i love a little
white chocolate macadamia oh
now you're talking yeah dude jesus flick
my [ __ ] while you're at it this is
when we're supposed to be turning our
year around this is when people go to
the gym this is like the month you're
right there's a lot of i'm sure with
those gym rats look at the the january
people the way we look at hobby comics
they're like you [ __ ] [ __ ] you don't
you don't take this seriously yeah you
have no idea you work in a cubicle
you're trying to live off some weird
fantasy it's not gonna last this is the
gauntlet this is thunderdome baby tahoes
those were good damns
oh cookies
all above my pay grade over here oh i'm
not yeah i don't i don't really get
cookies anymore honestly i don't know i
don't really buy them you can't buy them
because you eat them the first day you
know you pull them out of the bag you
put your eggs in your milk in the fridge
then you pull those maui's out and
you're done special occasion though i
will do like man they're like you know
milk bar sometimes you're just like i'm
just gonna order a milk bar
glass of milk movies that's a fun that's
a fun evening that is very nice because
you watch an old movie with some [ __ ]
sweets oh [ __ ] black and white movie
glass of milk comfort zone bro hell yeah
love it get a black white movie black
and white cookie now you're in yeah dude
i never liked the black and white cookie
i think it's overrated it kind of sucks
it's not great
the whole science thing they went with
the whole unity thing like right that
was a woke cookie back
then diversity yeah that was that was
their whole push white and black right
that's true and asians are like hello we
can't get in there hispanics nothing
pull up the tates if you can now we're
going we're going all google in this app
or
[Music]
let's not get carried away they're too
thin and hard
i don't like thin and hard
like my dick
but uh they're just too
i like a soft cookie i want grandma i
want the warmth i like crunchy yeah oh
you do like crunch probably crunchy so
it makes a mess yes that's the issue
yeah crunchy now we got crumbs
everywhere there's a little mouse
nibbling on the floor yeah you got that
right yeah not a fan that's why i don't
like the milan or the uh the and not the
intimates what's the [ __ ] on the plane
the best biscoff it's all crumb yeah we
have it on the plane though it's not
your problem kind of like trimming your
pubes in a hotel bathroom let's put this
on someone else which i'm also a fan of
that's where i get it done really yeah
i'm doing that at my house i'll leave a
big tip
i'll do it right over the toilet me too
i try to get it in but every once in a
while i have an off-shooting knife yeah
you got a rogue pube it's always gray
you got any grays yet yeah i've grazed
right here
oh yeah i got them on the side real bad
but i'm talking about pubes oh i don't
know actually
that's a bummer i'll check my teeth
[Laughter]
tates are overrated cookies yeah yeah
the green bag
i do like i do like those butter cookies
though that's a real killer whenever
someone it's holiday season and people
start bringing around those cookies or
like those how do you feel about the uh
schoolgirl cookies girl scout yeah
that's what i meant
uh i don't know they're school boy
cookies that's why i was confused yeah i
pulled up the school business they're
good they're good cookies school boys
those are another classic that's kevin
spacey's favorite
but
i don't know those oh that's a good
cookie yeah so you know those yeah i
didn't know they were called school boy
it's a little uh risque yeah school boy
well they they've the they have the girl
scout cookies but there's no boy scout
cookies because no one wants to give the
money because the first thought in your
head pedophilia that's right they're
using this money on trips yes this
[ __ ] guy with touchy fingers yeah
that was my money
you know who loves the
the boy scout pedophilia is the church
they're like thank god put it on those
weird campers
we'll be here at the vatican
[Laughter]
what about uh
the really good ones are the samoas
those are the classics
is that the is that the one with the
chocolate swirl on it that that weird
ribbon
the hole in it yeah that's it that's
like that's the best one that's the king
the thin mints can go [ __ ] themselves
get out of here the lemon up stink
toffee sticks i don't want to be
thinking about my breath when i'm eating
a cookie yes let me live a little
shortbread boring peanut butter that's
new that wasn't banging when i was back
in the uh
the rotation for a peanut butter cookies
as a kid was my go-to yeah
peanut butter you can't go wrong with
peanut butter and any sweet love peanut
butter peanut butter ice cream peanut
butter shake peanut butter
sauce
bread
well peanut sauce you got the pad thai
oh that's right so let's
let's give a toast to the peanuts yes
carver thank you
that looks like a [ __ ] little guinea
pig [ __ ]
what the hell is that cookie big shit's
my favorite uh punk band
you gotta go see guinea pig [ __ ]
you guys ready to rock
[Laughter]
guinea pigs are cute animals they are
have you seen those they're [ __ ]
they're adorable my friend had a few but
now they they they test things on guinea
pigs that's where we get the name awful
you're the guinea pig awful but is that
real i must be what have they tested on
a guinea pig space travel makeup what
are we talking here i had a guinea pig
as a kid really yeah i loved it snuggles
all right really to a legend i know but
they're just sitting that first of all
they say oh they play you you hand them
a carrot they nibble on it you can hold
them they they uh they go through little
mazes they're fun okay you can hold them
though i found out my mom uh
picked me up at school one day and she
goes snuggles died in the er and i was
like looking back is a pretty funny
sentence but as a kid i burst out crying
oh i get it i get it yeah yeah my cat
was killed as a kid
by the way my cat was just outdoors 98
of the time they're cute as hell those
animals cute cute animal look at that
they're a good size too they're not too
big not too small
but my cat was killed by a
a
banister was up against the wall and the
cat jumped on it it was like a piece of
a banister and they the cat jumped off
and the banister fell on top of it
crushed it oh that's awful i know my dad
was like do you want to see it or just
see it well he was like do you want to
say a word or whatever and i was like ah
just bury it damn i get it i couldn't
you lit it on fire like the end of star
wars
yeah yeah i said a prayer
i couldn't see it oh that's [ __ ]
brutal i know you know what i realized
guinea pigs they're really lucky they
don't have tails
yes because that's why no one likes the
uh the hamsters the gerbils because one
of them have tails possums got a wicked
tail they're gross people how about
people who have pet ferris what the [ __ ]
what a weird it's like if rockstar
energy drink was a animal
that's a bad luck to ferret they smell
weird they run all over the place
they're gross they're terrible bad move
white trash ferret it is white trash
yeah yeah you picture them opening the
door with like a miller light and a wife
beater yes
yes exactly i'm not drunk
you're drunk
cops just beating the [ __ ] out of him
yeah you got wwe's on in the background
they're playing some kid rock
yeah bad luck with the ferret
but
my friend had one how about the guy with
the snake
i mean that's a weird look what are we
even doing yeah his whole thing is well
feed him a mouse and he holds it up it's
it's a weird this guy wanted to not
develop a personality so bad he got into
[ __ ] reptiles oh yes you see that guy
in the west village and he's just uh
with all with the one on his shoulders
oh my god what are you doing that guy's
weird and also the uh the pigeon guy
you know the guy just sitting there he's
got 38 pigeons on his eye on his ass and
he's feeding them and [ __ ] you're like
what are you doing this is your day i
was like here i get it when you're like
a little kid and you want to like feed a
duck and you have to get like
the bread or something but like
feeding pigeons like these are birds
there's diseases like what are we doing
and look don't get me wrong culturally i
love the pigeons they're a part of the
city sure i see pigeons i get happy i go
to the you know atlantic city you get
the seagulls and you're like trash i'm a
pigeon man you know
but the but the goddamn or the uh
they're just kind of they're gross
animals rats with wings they say and
they nailed it i mean they're the worst
they're the gutter
like they they go through the gutter
they're they're bad they live in the
they go through the trash they need a
little short movie on them
they're fun animals they they're doing
this the whole time yeah yeah the
mixture they got grit you know they're
like uh like italian guys on a stoop you
know they've lived they've pictured them
with a cigarette shut up
the uh oh what is this is that a pigeon
movie
animaniacs had a uh oh disney wild i
don't know what that is
animaniacs had a whole sketch on pigeons
and they were they were called the the
good feathers
and it was like a bunch of mob guys who
were pit it was pretty great that's
pretty good yeah yeah yeah but they're
grimy they're they're gritty pigeons
make it work
they evolve what uh you got any peeves
this week um
big piece yeah now let me throw this at
you because it's a weird one and i might
need you to interact so you really
understand it
so i worked with a guy
and uh he had bad pauses
let me let me show you what i mean so
you know you're trying to bond with a
guy in the groom you don't know him that
well so you want to chit chat
let me throw one at you oh hey i like
those shoes oh good shoes you got there
you see what i'm saying uh we'll try
again uh
oh you got a haircut i did
you see the paws
he opens it up for a conversation and
then he slams you because he's thinking
oh it's still i'm still going but you
think i'll be polite and i'll chime in
it's we you don't think about time you
think about timing being like a showbiz
thing but like you need timing off stage
too it's everything totally i mean it
ruins the whole conversation so the
whole time we're going oh sorry uh
uh sweet guy nice guy but the pauses
were off all weekend
yeah exactly we couldn't build we
couldn't get anywhere and the whole
thing was ruined bad pauses
yeah that's rough bad
what are you drinking today
i'm having some time
like come on we can't do it
it's it's like the equivalent of like oh
you're in the wrong hole oh uh uh you
know it just felt like bad sex where you
couldn't get it right you know yeah the
whole thing was ruined
the whole weekend in the green room it
was just just
it sucked
that's tough yeah you know you want to
get into a good rhythm with a person
it's everything it's everything and then
you realize like oh i can't wait you get
back with your friends and you're like
ah
this is nice that's how people talk yeah
exactly and then you're like you have a
girlfriend how does she deal with it
maybe she's adapted to your bad pauses
so what i would do is because i want to
get along with him so i would just wait
way too long just to let him get it all
out and then i would chime in
yeah you just got to be really patient
yeah that's tough it was tough man
and it's a weird peeve i get it and i've
never encountered this i i you well the
second you said i'm like no i've had
those oh you have well yeah sure you
have people with weird speech patterns
and you have to kind of just you have to
wait it out yeah yeah
all right i feel better no i i had a
weird one i was checking into a building
uh
and it's one of those i don't know if
it's like a covet thing or whatever or
if it's just how the building runs
there's a guy at the front desk and he
was like
wait here for the elevator and there's
like a line i'm just like so i don't i
don't press the button he goes
yeah
oh that's weird this is not a normal
thing yeah you don't get annoyed you're
like you're throwing a weird thing at me
that was definitely a weird thing and i
don't like the the weird thing followed
by the annoyance yeah yeah you're weird
i'm reacting to your weirdness and
you're upset yeah how'd that happen
yeah i'm with you you don't do that with
other [ __ ] i mean like it's like meet me
on this corner
i'm gonna be an hour late and you're
like you're gonna be an hour late yeah
i'm gonna be late all right
right it's actually a pretty good move
on their part because now you win
somehow i'm the idiot but you're being
the douche you be you don't win because
i'm like this guy's a jerk off yeah
yeah he sucks so yeah you won't hang out
with them i mean i'm gonna hang out with
that desk guy anyway probably but yeah
yeah now i'm really not going now but
you want to meet his friends and go you
guys see this right i have so many
questions when i deal with weirdos like
that i think some guys
they're [ __ ] to strangers
i think some people like they're okay to
their select friend group or sometimes
they're just like an [ __ ] to even
some people in the friend group but
you've seen some of those people with
like this guy's got like a a
social problem yeah for sure
and then you're like how'd you get hired
you must have not done that in the
interview
is this your resume yeah it's my resume
[ __ ] exactly jesus christ i know
[ __ ] nerve of this guy people are
kooky
i watched uh here's my wreck yeah it's
not great i'm not proud of it but i
enjoyed it and it's a maybe a guilty
pleasure or whatever i watched king
richard oh i hear it's good oh did you
yeah okay it's a little hollywood-y and
they really glam it up but the story is
so good that i had to watch it but it's
got you know the cheese on it and it's
sad and heartwarming and all that [ __ ]
so much cheese but the story's amazing
these two gals from compton the dad
worked him in the rain the hood the
violence the gunshots the racism with
the country club pretty fascinating so
interesting like sports like tennis and
golf and the histories of racism and
then it's like once you start letting
people of different races and look what
the [ __ ] happened right the william
sisters tiger woods hello i know but
maybe that's why they didn't want to let
them in
you know
well you see old footage of like
basketball in the 50s and just like a
white guy like
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah i think we need to do you guys want
ratings to go up or do you want to win
right
the washington generals yeah playing the
globetrotters and the simpsons so good
oh that's what we have a crusty bed all
on them and he's like i thought the
generals would do
that was a bit i tried to do but it got
too dicey about uh like transgender
people are like dominating in all these
sports and i'm like that must be how
white people felt in the 50s when black
people came in like we can't let them
play they're going to win everything oh
that's good you like that yeah maybe
i'll bring it back it just got it's it's
race it's trained ender it was a lot of
different edgy [ __ ] and i think people
pulled back but
certain things people just don't want a
[ __ ] a piece you know i know i'm not
good with that it's just certain subject
matter yeah it's not even what you're
saying i'm not saying anything wrong but
i had an abortion joke and a woman just
heckled like like what [ __ ] you like got
real pissed i'm like it's a joke i'm
obvious i opened my saying on pro-choice
i made a joke but she was like really
got worked up and we kind of had a funny
exchange
by the end because i think she could
tell that i wasn't an [ __ ] yeah and
she regretted a little bit good
but uh she kept being like why can't i
have a bunch of abortions i was like i'm
saying you can yeah yeah i was like you
could do it i mean like do whatever you
want and then and i said i said she i
said 12 abortions or something and she
goes why can't i have 12. i was like
well you know you interrupt comedy shows
clearly you make a lot of mistakes you
might have to get 12.
that's great
i think some people just want to yell
you know they're like here we go this is
my chance and you're like oh you're not
actually trying to like do
good or have justice or save the day you
just want to get something out
yeah i also think people make like a
prejudgment sometimes early in your set
if you try to go a little too uh
you know edgy early on they're just a
little bit like what who the hell do you
think you are and you got to earn it a
little more so maybe it was on me for
doing it too early in the set
but also i'm kind of like let's all
relax guys yeah it's comedy show why are
you primed already why are you
ready to be set off that's the weird way
well they might be primed and they're
going for the combination of the escape
so they don't want some people don't
want to be challenged that's true some
people just want like silliness and so
look you know we all want different
things with entertainment but that's why
when you go to a show like at the seller
you get five or six comics they're not
all gonna be for you right right right
and that's okay just sit back it'll last
ten minutes and you're good yeah you
don't have to challenge everything but
like michelle wolf
a friend of ours did the correspondence
dinner years ago and she had this whole
thing about
you guys hate trump you yell at trump
but i think you kind of love trump
because he gives you mean it gives you
purpose and i i think there's a lot to
that oh my god i mean
you think cnn won't kill for trump right
now exactly they just lost cuomo yeah
that was the highest rated guy they'd
love trump right now that's true and
then that's weird so you say you hate
them but you actually love them i know a
couple people who the january 6th thing
happened and they were like this is
great yeah and you're like i thought it
was bad i thought it was a horrible
thing and uh you know it wasn't bad for
america yeah yeah but they're like oh
this is this is horrible we love it we
got something it's fodder now we got
ammo but once the anger is gone you kind
of have to look at yourself
right or you have to find something else
to be angry about and maybe it's harder
to find so exactly once the anger is
gone there's sadness i think i think
you're right there's almost over yeah
hangover like a feeling of loss yes yes
you get you get drunk on the uh outrage
and then the hangover sets in i hope
yeah or they're just like no i'm great
all the time i'm right about everything
yeah i feel like internalizing has gone
away a little
yeah you know a lot a lot of things are
just like you suck you suck everything's
bad i'm great but everything the
country's bad but i'm great you know
you're like maybe you're not great it's
weird because you'd think like the
internalizing
would be like that's when people would
blow up because it's so much pent-upper
age but it's almost like people never
internalize now yeah everything's out
and they still have the energy to always
be angry yeah isn't that weird good
point you think like the guy who blows
up is like humphrey bogart one of his
characters right at like age 55 when
he's just like
yeah it's just like a dude who's doing
that every day yes have you seen this
right
where does that come i would kill for
that energy well you know what i i'm
with him but i think it's inside i think
they're mad at their dad they're mad at
whatever they're mad at something of
themselves so they have it it's just
it's just ever glowing burning inside
them that they have all this energy
because it's in them because they won't
face that energy oh when you meet people
who are angry all the time and always
like why can't i'm like if you're not
even if you've never even tried therapy
i don't want to hear it i know because
you're taking that [ __ ] out on everyone
but you yeah which is toxic yeah we talk
about everything stocks he talks about
i'm like maybe you're toxic i'm not
saying everyone needs therapy but you
know the dude i'm talking about yeah
guys like i don't not for me and you're
like you're like the one dude who needs
it the most right right yeah totally
and like i think everybody should try it
you say not everybody but try it
yeah it's not everybody needs it
you never know what you'll get out of it
yeah good shrink really seems to care
yeah
we went a long time without one of those
yeah what uh
so that's your i'm trying to think about
my record i i watched a bunch of watched
a bunch of noirs lately
uh a lot of good
a lot of good stuff on um criterion i'm
doing another criterion movie because
i've just been burning through them yeah
but dude any hitchcock movie honestly oh
yeah
my wreck is is i think uh uh rear window
is one of my favorites if you haven't
seen vertigo man oh come on that's like
as good as it gets i love that notorious
all those old hitchcock movies [ __ ]
rule yeah yeah the best the camera work
the tension he builds that tension and
then just releases it it's great we
might be drunk is sponsored by better
help what's standing in the way of
achieving your goals a lot
figure it out with better help uh you
know look i've i'm in therapy it's been
very very big for me i i love it uh he's
he's definitely helped oh yeah i just
talked to him yeah yeah great guy great
therapist better help is therapy for the
21st
uh century better help is professional
therapy all online it's all remote do it
from the comfort and privacy of your own
home flexible schedule phone or video
calls at your convenience get a good
match they will put you with a licensed
therapist who is right for you that's
the most important part of therapy you
need someone to feel like you can talk
to them who gets you it's fast when you
sign up you can start talking to your
therapist in less than 48 hours no
waiting around it's affordable you
didn't have to be rich to pay for this
it's uh and financial aid available this
is great and now you can send messages
to your therapist any time paul what
about bob bill murray great movie great
movie they'll get back to you in between
sessions don't like your person if you
want to switch therapists you can do it
anytime for free trust me it helps have
someone outside your world to talk to
it's easy to schedule affordable and
will take a load of off your shoulders
over 100 over a million people have
taken charge of their mental health join
them tell them how to do it mark
better help as a special offer for our
listeners visit betterhelp.com
drunk for 10 off your first month that's
better help
h-e-l-p dot com
drunk for 10 off your first month
betterhelp.com slash drunk sign up for
better help to start living a happier
life today just try it folks you don't
like it don't keep going nate pergotzi
jerry seinfeld you're both kooks get
some therapy you chooch
yeah it's good stuff i don't know i have
so many wrecks another wreck is just you
know
try to [ __ ] relax this year
that's another wreck like we're all at
each other's throats yeah you know let's
all try to get along like you look at
the country and you're just kind of like
hey let's uh
let's just [ __ ] be people again i
know and look we're racist we're sexist
we're homophobe we got our problems the
border abortion like there's problems
but
you can get grubhub
anytime you want you know we got
ubereats we got netflix on the on the
dial it's all right there it's all on
your phone you can see the weather you
can call your aunt it's all right there
porn is free
yeah you know
a lot of pets yeah you're right that is
a [ __ ] when you got your dick in hand
they're like get your dick bigger you're
like come on i'm trying to get off how
about when you get these thin hotel
walls and you're like he he definitely
heard my computer say welcome to jerk
mate oh my goodness
but you know it's really uh
everything is
there's a lot of problems but a lot is
good is good we do tend to focus on the
bad rather than good and i think you
know which is a sign of good i think if
you focus on the bad that means you've
got time to focus on the bad words i
think that's so think about when you
like fight with your girlfriend even
it's like you have a lot of you both
have too much free time and there's like
a fight is just created right you don't
fight when you're busy that's true
that's true yeah you got a 15-minute
window you're not working in a fight
fighting is a privilege it's a privilege
interesting yeah you're right you're
right yeah yeah we got we got it pretty
good yeah we fought for four hours last
night must be nice
yes
i was tilling a field or uh you know
pulling a mule or some [ __ ]
so yeah then you hear about all this
slavery in china with the middle
easterners and all this [ __ ] you're like
chinese people can only be on tick tock
for two hours a day or whatever not to
pick on china that's i mean that sounds
fair that sounds pretty good i think we
could all use the limit
yeah i agree i mean that's like i'm
obviously not but at the same time
do you need to be on tick tock for more
than two hours a day no i know it's the
same [ __ ] over and over is that real two
hours that's the limit yeah it's
twerking it's cats it's it's a fist
fight whatever it is
uh
tell me you're from the 90s without
saying it like all right all right is
this what we're doing you could learn
the xylophone i always get the guy who's
like look at this [ __ ] breakfast
burrito oh look how juicy that [ __ ] is
i'm like all right dude i know look look
at this [ __ ] let's see if it's the best
burrito and
it's [ __ ] good yeah and that's got 18
million 18 million you work on a bit for
six months 40 000 views it's brutal i
know i can't figure out that algo you
you film yourself going hey i got a
boner i'm farting and they go hey this
is gold and then you put out a killer
bid with a hot crowd nothing nothing
yeah it's very strong well tick tock is
one where it just mutes everything like
everything i put up there they're just
like muted really yeah i guess i should
offensive to their algorithm i have no
idea
i don't know folks this ain't good all
this muting and censoring like then we
go to youtube then maybe they'll start
censoring that's the worry honestly it's
like we all act like whatever like look
it starts with obviously like i think
the cueing on people whatever they're
all [ __ ] nuts but like it starts with
that [ __ ] sometimes and you do have to
worry that yeah they keep moving the
goal line in well this joke wasn't good
well guess what when it's uh an
algorithm that can't detect sarcasm like
we might say [ __ ] up [ __ ] and we're
clearly kidding yeah and then all of a
sudden now we're getting buried and it
is dangerous for uh
self-produced content yes we rely on
ticket sales we rely on eyeballs seeing
it and i'm seeing it a little bit
already really i am are you not at all i
guess i don't monitor that much i should
i see it a little bit it's definitely
dropped on instagram we used to get half
a million views and [ __ ] on his now it's
like it's like a hundred times
saturated that's true too that's also so
funny to be complaining about we have
these like offensive
jokes and we're like why didn't it do
better yeah
well hey i like offensive comedy i know
i assume other people do too especially
in this world of sensor i think people
want to get a little dirty
yeah dude what uh what else is going
where where you got uh where are you
going coming up this month i'm excited
i'm going to i'm going to west coast a
lot i'm doing la jolla comedy store it's
like the beverly hills of san diego san
diego rules san diego is amazing the
people are great it's just it's another
world out there you know every time i go
to san diego i'm like why don't i live
here what am i doing this place is
magical there's palm trees the sun is
shining
the beach even the homeless guys look
like hugh jackman there it's crazy i
know they got full heads of hair they're
rugged yeah it's true i don't know what
i'm thinking they got nice cars and
beautiful women and the drinks are
flowing and the bars are full it's great
and then i come back to new york and i
get [ __ ] on by a pig and i'm like all
right this fits
but yeah yeah i'm going to la jolla
that's have you been there i love it
yeah that's a great club great club
magical classic club sacramento i like
that club not a not a lively town
sacramento i'll be there in february
yeah oh nice it's it's got its charm but
you gotta find it
i feel like a lot of dudes like look
like they think they're ufc fighters in
sacramento yeah i'm like this dude's
gonna put me in a rear naked show cause
i cut him in line or something you know
i'm like i didn't cut you he's like
yeah neck tattoo he's got the weird
haircut with the sides are short
yeah i got uh when i i'm in toronto i
mean have you done so you just did
vancouver is it weird the the customs
going through security that was a
nightmare really yeah well i
didn't tell you my story no ah buckle up
for this one trench coat
all right so
got my covet test you gotta have a test
within whatever 72 hours really yeah you
got to do that got the test i was like
that's not a big deal i get it i'm going
to do another country
got the test got the flight you got to
connect in seattle you can't go straight
there anymore so i was like all right
whatever it's a [ __ ] six-hour flight
you make it i get to seattle i go
alright i'm going to air canada going to
vancouver they go you got your test i go
oh i did the test i'm i'm a good guy
you're showing your phone showed up by
phone and they go
um when you get this test i go i don't
know tuesday they go mmm supposed to be
72 hours and they do
74. oh my god and i go well come on i
don't have covid it's 72 74. i got your
test i did it i just flew here from new
york city six hours cross country and
they go
74.
so i go what do i do they go we can get
a later flight and go get a test right
now and i'm like well then i'll never
make the two shows
and they go ah sorry
i go what the [ __ ] they go well you
might as well get tested and then maybe
you can make it so i got tested there's
a line to get tested the test results
take an hour so i go [ __ ] it
i rent a car
i take the test rent a car start driving
to the border it's a three hour drive i
get the results after an hour and a half
of driving i'm already halfway there hit
the border show him the test
drove to the gig damn it was a nightmare
but i pulled it off
damn yeah i had to rent a car
with going into other countries now but
god this sucks i know this [ __ ] sucks
even the passport is annoying i'm like
oh where's the hell's back yeah i've got
that uh i think now if you have the
enhanced id you don't need a password
also do you have the
the global entry thing
no i wish why don't you get you have
that yeah i thought you'd be a spy or a
president to have that why who's got
global entry what are you james bond
what do you barack obama who's gonna
who's gonna
i think most comics who do the road have
a global entry global interest so elite
it sounds like it's like pre-check for
[ __ ] canada really yes that might
wait
like i've never heard of this global
entry
that sounds great that sounds like
you're [ __ ] uh foreign women
yeah dude
global entry frequently asked questions
uh oh i can't read that but yeah what
the hell either way yeah wendy how how
long do you think until you need glasses
uh
good question my dad has them i'm
getting there i think really i mean look
at this [ __ ] this i mean are we supposed
to be able to every time you do an eye
test it gets worse i know well we've
been drinking too
that doesn't help the eye test
uh
create a trusted traveler program
account i'm already out i can't make an
account 100 non-refundable fees required
each application oh they just lost
norman yeah
can't do it
uh you will need to bring a valid
password all right all right this
doesn't sound so bad it's i think it's
worth it it's
somewhere okay you'd have this
yeah how'd you do it you just went to
the place to get it dmv
it's wherever i got the pre-check i
think i wonder if i could knock them
both out one day
you should do this [ __ ] man where is
that global entry enrollment center you
got a uh you gotta you got an office
i'll go tomorrow i got the day off get
it up dude i will
matt you might need to help him with
this i don't think mark's gonna do it
this might be like health insurance or
march like oh yeah do it cut to a week
later he's like yeah i'm not doing it
yeah you got to come with me i need you
i need your support i got to hold your
hand the whole time
anything with accounts or logins
dude my add too i'm like i'm on i'm like
[ __ ] this [ __ ] it was just so easy
before you go i'd like this here's the
money and there you go that was it it
was a it was a transaction
god it's [ __ ] being an adult is
exhausting i don't feel like anytime i'm
doing something that's like not comedy
related i'm just like what am i doing i
know i know
and it's getting bad though i'm at a
barbecue with people i love and i'm like
ah i should be writing i look at bills
and i'm just like yeah i could be
writing a joke [ __ ] yeah oh i know
bills are tough because you're losing
money and it's a nightmare to do i know
so it's a double whammy but you got to
do it gotta do it but like seinfeld
would park anywhere and he would get
tickets on his porsche and i was like oh
man that sucks you got a 60 ticket he's
like
let's give it to my assistant they pay
it i'm like oh that's pretty good i got
a ticket i sit down i got the i got a
red red visor on with the with the
papers going the cigar i like do my
finances figure it all out put a stamp
on it write the letter
mail it in he's like i just give it to
them being a billionaire sounds good
yeah must be nice
that's hilarious he just breaks the law
and he's like help someone else deal
with it that's fine great because we are
so worried about financial
um penalties he doesn't have that worry
so he can just do whatever he wants i
think epstein didn't have that worry
either i think he just did whatever he's
like i'll have my assistant deal with it
yeah that's true
and she's on trial
why can't we get that trial on air by
the way
it's weird i i was listening to one
podcast that said that she's getting the
her lawyers like he's now that he's the
state couldn't keep him open and he's
dead so
there's all this anger says there's no
resolution for his victims
so she's kind of getting the brunt of
the blame but then the other people were
like but
you were the assistant she was the
recruiter she was the scout yeah you
kind of
uh
greased the wheels a little here i heard
you blew clooney do you hear that really
that came out today yeah google that huh
sounds like they were casamigos
yes damn just the facts alone fine day
yeah three kings
that didn't work
to think of another clue batman burn
after reading i don't know
burn after anal
um but yeah she did that's what i heard
damn she was in a tryst
boasted about triss with clooney oh
clooney man who hasn't he head
well done clooney i'm sure he's not
bragging about that one no no no
giddy is a school girl after performing
oral sex on clooney in a bathroom at a
show business event
that's how hot george clooney is you
blow him in a bathroom and you're like
girls gather round
yes tell the reporters she had given
cloney a blowj clooney a [ __ ] in the
bathroom in some renovation all right
she never let that one down there you go
billionaire's playboy club
love to brag about her rendezvous with
various lovers
damn now i'd like to hear that on the
trial what was his deck like how was it
did it smell with her pubes talk to me
jizz
there's a playboy club right by here i
really i did a gig there once uh
yeah adam glenn you know adam
good he was yeah he works tmz he booked
me on it and he was like
he's so funny because he like
he's such a good schmoozer but he could
tell
he was like we got sam morell here to
the person uh you know who runs the club
he's like can we get him a membership no
dudes and she was like uh yeah i'll see
what i could do you could tell she was
like go [ __ ] yourself right but he's
like he just performed at the club but
it's like they have like big he's like
they have pajama parties it's all
ridiculous yeah they have pajama parties
dude oh
man that's good playmates
but it does feel like an out of place in
time thing doesn't it it does and if we
went there like as single guys they'd be
like who were they yeah like why are you
here yeah there's like basketball
players and celebrities there and we're
like hello yeah by celebrities like is
that steve guttenberg what the hell
the hell is this what year is this i
know
i'm sure gutenberg and guys like that
can ride out the dad issues on some
ladies like i watched police academy
when i was six i thought you were so
cute
yeah i'm sure yeah i think they prey on
that whole thing at that age
yeah like bob sagan i'm sure has all
kinds of young girls oh my god he's
married now oh okay well i'm saying the
before his marriage i bet he got a lot
of like oh my god i watched you every
night you know you got it dude
[ __ ] full house man yeah she said
who's so bad he's [ __ ] her in the ass
she's like have mercy
i love him he's such a good dude now you
think he's living off that house a full
house is that just that's got to be
royalties for decades i think he's very
well off really like i mean would you
think i mean yeah it must be bob saget
net worth boy these are all right these
are gonna say we're worth 25 though so
you gotta put that into account
that's bittersweet for uh oh 50 mil yeah
i thought it'd be more
what is it
okay i bet he's got more yeah i think so
i mean you think about
how long he's been famous and if you you
know invest and yeah
and two prime time shows in the 80s two
america's funniest home videos
plus touring plus movies plus
yeah afv i forgot directed dirty work
yeah that's right i'm sure that didn't
bring in a big [ __ ] but yeah spotted
some good stories though so great great
movie you know i just watched the kenny
g documentary what i'm just curious
because you hear it kenny g's a punch
line he's a joke the guy's amazing was
it good
it's all right but uh you get to know
him a little more he's a jew from
seattle he's obsessed with he's a
perfectionist he's like i want to be the
best dad i want to be the best clarinet
player i want to be the best piano
player i want to be the best sax
he's a golfer he's a pilot i mean the
guy's a nightmare
wow he just never stops
i mean the guy is very impressive he
invested in starbucks before anybody
that was another couple mill he made
great sex can do all the the genres
it's incredible it's a it's an
eye-opener
because all you hear about this guy oh
he's a goof he's kenny g with the hair
and the sax and the muzak you know he's
in the dentist's office
you're getting a cavity filled but the
guy is a genius it is weird where they
play his music i know that's got to be
rough that's like if you're an artist
and you're really successful but your
work is known for like a la canta right
right all right yeah yeah you're in the
waiting room with a gyno
yeah that's like jani or something yeah
who's yani he's a greek guy he does uh
he does the sounds of stuff what what
what is it i don't know what was that
bit about him oh really
well they did all these jokes they
played a string of jokes about um like
snl and all these guys making fun of
kenny g and he's like yeah it sucks but
i'm awesome he's very like uh sure of
himself oh okay yeah which i don't have
that
if a bunch of news stories are not news
story but like comedy shows were about
you and they were [ __ ] on you yeah
that would hurt i'd be crushed that'd be
tough look at these guys with the hair
what are they thinking you have to be
very confident
they don't have a lot of friends going
you sure that's what it is you need some
of those friends like think about if we
rolled into the comedy cellar with hair
i mean first of all i don't have hair
like that so i can but
but if you did oh yeah i'll look like a
racer head if this [ __ ] keeps going
right but i mean
imagine rolling in with that hair they'd
just be like well look at this pretty
boy you just get [ __ ] railed i have
that at the gap i'm in the i'm in the
green room on the grid the dressing room
like oh look at this jacket it's like a
leather jacket and i just hear every
high school friend going what are you
[ __ ] crazy a piece of [ __ ] you can't
pull that off and i take it right off
they followed you to go shopping yeah
they're still there
uh yeah no man it's i'm with you i put
on a jacket i'm just like who do you
think you are no i know what the [ __ ] do
you think you are
you know you gotta we gotta push through
we gotta grow up
kenneth
apparently i'm on law and order svu yeah
is that count chocula
i'm a vampire hunter
[Laughter]
yeah but look i mean look at him he's a
walking punch line but
he's very sure of himself he's confident
his name's kenneth gorlick
he's obsessed with music he said he
practices three hours a day still he
looks like a number two panther pencil
with a hair net or something it's like
[ __ ]
yeah two hours a day three that's a lot
still goes still going well i mean
that's how you become one of the best
that's what it is yeah what what channel
is the doc on hbo is doing this whole
music box thing and it's got like
everybody and but they're picking
interesting um
interesting people to use
kenny g i think uh
they're doing a whole
a whole run of people who are you
wouldn't think about music but they're
huge when is hbo going to become global
they're not no i think netflix is and
youtube are the only global ones really
i think that's why
ghost comedy specials just don't do as
well yeah i guess you're right um i
don't know i thought they were global
hbo
they have like 40 million subscribers
compared to netflix like 210 million oh
wow yeah crazy but how many of those are
stolen passwords
you know i mean that they got to cut
that in half
really i'm not paying for it are you
netflix no i'm not that's like the only
one i don't pay for that's my dad's
account i pay for all the others yeah i
don't pay for any really and i steal
cable outside of that
you should keep saying this oh yeah
you're right
you're going to be in court they're like
he steals cable you're like no i don't
roll the footage
i steal cable
i still get every episode matt you and i
steal cable well when's the last time
you watched live tv on your tv set i
mean i know sports i'll do sports oh
sports yeah that's it no news
i do news but i do the channels that
come with my tv so it's like i have a
samsung so you get like cbs news you get
like
you get
yeah i don't really watch cable news
much occasionally on the road i do it's
just it's like noise in the hotel yeah
well you get why kids don't do it
because you go through the guide and
you're like there's nothing on it's like
ginsu knives uh [ __ ] what's that
c-span
it's horrible
you know it's weird you're like it's
like russian roulette but they're all
bullets
you know it just sucks you're like how
are these all [ __ ] bad
um it's true golden girls is on you know
then you got to sit through commercials
there's nothing good on there
yeah it's weird it's like uh it's kind
of like pandora where you're like just
hope but it's like pandora for [ __ ] you
don't like yeah at least you put in
something you like but you know you you
kind of give them this random [ __ ] and
you're like i mean there is a weird
satisfaction though when you're flipping
and you land on something you like that
is nice like same with the radio if
you're just like because you don't use a
radio much either anymore but if you if
you just like you're doing it
and then you hit like oh [ __ ] teenage
wasteland that was co you know what i
mean yeah that's a good point or like
you're scrolling on tv and you're like
oh office rerun that's cool but it's so
[ __ ]
but then you think about you're like why
could just pick any episode of whatever
exactly and then you know you just look
where it's streaming but i guess there
is that excitement factor i know and
that's where i gotta cool it because
i'll be like these kids today and then i
just slowly wean off too i become like
them because it just it's better
it's better but then also it's like we
talk about how expensive cable is but
then how many like streamers do you have
to buy to watch what you want you know i
know that's how they get you
did you ever have a kid like we didn't
have cable growing up for a while my
dad's like we don't need that and then
eventually we got it
um but i wonder if there's kids now who
are like come on dad get netflix we're
we're watching tv here
i think most parents i think i think the
reason disney is number two is because
of kids oh well i hope everyone has
kids are special needs adults
who else is watching uh just a
six-year-old man in a turtleneck honey
do you want to watch hawkeye the series
yeah exactly um yeah no it's uh
it's [ __ ] weird it's i guess disney
channel was huge for i mean they could
just parents just put it on and you're
like but they're all the marvel stuff
and they have i mean they do have
simpsons you know they do yeah that's
the big thing that for like guys like us
but yeah they have like you know they
have the beatles thing
that's disney that's disney plus whoa
they do have some stuff but yeah they
have a lot it's mostly for kids and i
think they have espn
they own espn i don't know if they have
it on this so maybe they own it they
have like uh gary when disney starts
owning [ __ ] well you get that nostalgia
[ __ ] where you get like the x-men like
remember
i love that
wolverine was like a comic oh yeah
cyclops was like a [ __ ] perfectionist
wolverine was like the bad boy who just
like didn't play by the rules yes hell
yeah dude yeah one of the rare comics
with stubble
yeah you know he was grungy he was
gritty he had a short too he was sure he
was angry he was short
yeah short guys are pissed and then he
had you know could heal really quickly
which uh after a few of these i wish i
had yeah the two never got hung over
good point
they never talk about that well you got
herpes like i'll be good
girl's like hey we're teaming up as we
speak i got chlamydia he's like i'll
still [ __ ] you
she's like you better wear a condom he's
like ah
wolverine did not wear condoms no no
there was two he was like the first
depressed uh superhero we were exposed
to yeah but you gotta watch out for the
fingering
easy wolfy
you're on your period no i'm not [ __ ] i
think i just killed you
yeah he was he was like a depressed
superhero he was always like sad you're
right what happened his mom died
something happened he was just he was
just he never got the girl it's like
cyclops got the girl he was just like a
said though that was a good show
that was a good show professor x was in
a wheelchair beast was smart gambit was
fun
loved gambit as a new orleans guy gambit
was big because he had the cards and uh
how you doing [ __ ] i guarantee you know
they made them all okay
oh gambit game of [ __ ] rock yeah
it's funny how comic books we [ __ ] on
them like oh this guy's a comic book guy
he's a nerd he's a virgin he can't get
laid get out of the basement you live
with your mom but then they make so much
money
so then like you get huge nerds make
money i mean what's look at tech
look at tech
tech was never going to run the
zuckerberg's a nerd
yeah i think that was a flip
you know like nerd
revenge of the nerds was like a crazy
idea it's a comedy revenge of the nerds
get out of here come on nerds would win
then you re-watch it there's at least
two rape scenes in that movie you're
like all right this ain't good they're
like panty rage you're like that's you
can't do a panty raid is like that's
over yeah that's over or the one where
he just like bangs her in the
boyfriend's costume i'm like you tricked
a woman in the bank this is crazy and
then he ate her out
that's basically the houdini remember
the houdini
but then at the end they play queen we
are the champions they're like ah [ __ ]
it they they earned it
that movie was uh i loved it as a kid oh
for sure yeah john goodman the bad guy
yeah lamarr remember
can we get that song
when the nerds yeah clap your hand
everybody yeah with anthony edwards that
dude are we gonna get demonetized if we
do that no we might and [ __ ] it don't do
it
now they're gonna have a movie called
revenge of the of the jocks they have to
go the other way the nerds are bullying
them you'll never get into college like
these [ __ ] nerds yeah right you don't
know how to do taxes they're in they're
in a huddle for football the girls are
blowing the nerds because like he's
gonna be really successful
right guys we gotta win this game we
need a scholarship that's true they're
like you know how to do robin hood
bitcoin what a [ __ ] return
yeah you're right they made four of
those they really started slipping yeah
remember booger booger was the
he was the [ __ ] man i loved booger
they had a 10-year run 84-94
three and four were pretty terrible i
didn't even know about those i watched
them all as a kid wow
number two barry sobel that's right
big part he had a run yeah we know barry
sobel we know him not bragging
i mean that guy was a phenom in the 80s
uh stand-up comic did carson blew it out
front open for thompson for eddie murphy
that's right
with punchline i used to walk around the
city with barry sobel and he all these
black guys were like very so well so i'm
like every you know every black guy is
like i did eddie murphy's show once and
that was it
what is uh can you pull up his thing on
doctor cats i wonder if they have that
barry and doctor
talk about a throwback doc doctor
[ __ ] oh barry with an e oh it's an egg
there we go there he is
dr katz
dr katz was a show on comedy central
that had squiggly lines oh can you pull
that up let's see there we go
are they gonna kill us because comedy
central is a bunch of cheapskates
sympathetic place in the world you go
the person behind the counter whose job
it is to help you i say you know i've
lost my luggage typical in new york
style the person goes yeah that's all i
need now you and your bags
what do you what do you want me to pick
up the airport and shake it through your
bags fling out who am i question what am
i yuri geller shirley maclaine in the
head what am i what am i a magician uh
david copperballs what
was this psychic bags balls network did
you know your bags went to san jose
excuse me
excuse me i think you're a little out of
line i hear something you know what your
bags look like and you can't find them i
don't know what they look like
ah
man barry sobel huge that was
entertainment back in the doctor
oh fun show and a brilliant joke writer
by the way i love his stuff he did he
used to joke about uh i just did a
benefit for the uh the survivors of the
last benefit i did
[Laughter]
wow that's his yeah that's great classic
i think he's in a wheelchair now i think
he's ms oh damn he was so funny so that
show is incredible great show i love him
telling the joke and doctor guys goes
what yeah
i mean it's so funny what is such an
underrated punchline what what
yeah that's gold do you have any bits
you're working on oh
boy you shouldn't have asked i'm
backlogged i finally had a like a rush
of material
me too took a took long enough for me
i got two hmm
the question is which one i'll try this
one yeah i'm in the same boat so i got
this car now and i'm like i'm actually
trying to invest in the car like i'm
changing the oil i'm putting fluids in
it i'm like trying to be hands-on with
the car and it makes you love the car
more you know i'm
out there
and i made me realize
thank god babies take nine months
because if you could make a baby in five
minutes as a woman they'd all be in the
dumpster
because you need that time to fall in
love with it you work hard for it you
have the labor labor of love you know
and like imagine you're like oh i got a
hot date tonight i'm pregnant i'll make
one
when it's over you know if a baby was
that easy to make you wouldn't care
about it as much
interesting that's all i got yeah yeah
if a baby were that interesting or that
easy to make
you wouldn't give a [ __ ] yeah it's like
fast food versus a gourmet meal right
you really prepare it yeah you care
about it because this this took care
this took work yes which is probably why
so many men leave because they didn't do
any of the work they just got off you
know and the baby is done
but she was like i love this thing
you're just gonna leave the family and
he's like i'm good
while your mom gets so mad when you
don't appreciate a meal she works really
hard yes exactly that took me eight
hours i'm sorry it's good yeah yeah i
gotta go i gotta i gotta see my friends
but the baby takes so long to make for a
woman that they love it thank god it
would be horrible if they were made in
five minutes because you just keep
making them i'll make another one
but the fact that it's hard to do
makes you appreciate i don't know if
they throw them in the dumpster if they
make my phone but like yeah you would
you would keep trying yeah this one
looks weird yes
exactly i could just knock this out
again in five minutes
but the process of it makes it really
worth something
that's all i got but i feel like there's
something there i could play with that
and this is starting with the car yeah i
could start with anything but the car is
where i got the idea
it's satisfying the baby is um
it's like a rich kid who's given
everything he doesn't appreciate it then
he ends up on opioids you know because
he's got no
it's the satisfaction of something comes
from the work uh working on it right
but but i don't know because that's the
angle because the dad is satisfied too i
think what do you mean because he got
off
no because there's a baby i don't think
he's not happy with the baby i think so
i think that's tough
right right
the the dead well the dad stays with the
woman and the wife or whatever and they
they work on it together she's pregnant
he's helping her
then he's invested
that's true so he's like the sous chef
yeah there you go she's the chef he's
like he's like seasoning she's really
doing the heavy lifting right right yeah
the dad like i'll do the dishes you know
yeah the diaper
right yeah oh that's a good aspect the
the cook part
it is like a meal you labor over yes
and you care more about it you get
grubhub you're like ah there it is
you know that's good but if you really
sit there with the food and the sauce
and the seasoning and prepare it it
means more to it well the takeout is
kind of like a one-night stand you got
the wrappers yeah you toss it out right
right imagine a one-night stand calling
you go
i'm pregnant you're like oh that was you
know that was a pizza you know i'm done
yeah
i don't know could be something there's
something here but i think the idea of
like
you're invested but then i'm trying like
an adoption angle too because
you know you're like you care because
you did the work but you also like oh
that's good but then also if you can't
get a meal you're grateful for a meal
yeah
yeah i'm trying to think about oh yeah i
don't know i'm trying to open this up
we'll work for food yeah yeah well i
think that adoption process is a
nightmare yeah so you almost kind of
earn it there too and you can't have a
baby yourself so it does mean more
yeah
there's something here for sure yeah
okay okay i'll noodle i like the
adoption angle tell me if you've heard
this before
because i'm like i like this idea and i
don't know if it's been done before it
sounds like maybe someone could have
done i want to make sure they haven't
mm-hmm so there you saw that congressman
holding all the guns
no there was that picture that
congressman you you saw what i'm talking
about right hold on with his family the
whole family's holding the rifles
is this the the shooter in michigan no
that was the crumbly or whatever that
was a different thing
um yeah you saw this well i did not see
this oh really why would you think about
how like these people when they post gun
pictures they always act like they're
responsible gun owners but like you're
posting it because you think you look
cool
like it's like if you're responsible how
come these people never post a picture
with a fire extinguisher ah
like you never see them posters like a
fire extinguisher like i hope i never
have to use this but if i do i'll
[ __ ] do it dude yeah that's true you
know like that's have you heard
something like that no i like it okay
and fire strings should have a safety on
it too
yeah i one of the lines was i'll spray a
whole school i don't give a [ __ ] yeah
that's not it though that's not what i'm
going right right i can do better than
that but i think like there's something
there right i love that yeah and that's
a firearm and the fire extinguisher
maybe your arm's on fire you got to put
it out i'm reaching there's something
here yeah i love that they talk about
responsibility that's the angle yeah and
you're just like this isn't about
responsibility this is you think you
look cool yeah no one's holding up
condoms yeah
no one's posting an instagram picture
with a divorce lawyer i'm happily
married but just in case yeah
just in case i have to use this yeah
fire extinguisher is funny though
because it's also an object that shoots
exactly i like that a lot that's big
um should we plug dates oh yeah i mean
did we do we get it in
oh okay i got i'm in toronto i believe
this comes out the first week of january
so i'll be here on friday and uh that's
january 7th uh at sump theater i forgot
it's on my website
uh one night only baby so i hope i see
or maybe we had hopefully we added one
who the hell knows but yeah i'll be
there i'll be at uh
i'll be at uh richmond virginia sandman
uh january i'll be at timonium maryland
uh hartford connecticut
sacramento columbus ohio uh i think when
i had an la date hopefully add san diego
and houston at some point we'll see
samurail.com shows and the big one is
beacon theater may 7th you better come
out baby new york city
can't beat that beacon that's gonna be
epic you gotta because i hope you guys
come out in new york go support and
email us stuff uh we might be drunk pod
at gmail.com rex peeves jokes drinks
whatever mark where are you gonna be
you're here yes yes send us anything
you've got a patreon packages to gotham
studios on 38th street
uh i'm at sacramento punchline
then the uh the stress factory in
connecticut
uh tulsa oklahoma they got a new club
now oh nice uh
cincinnati funny bone the liberty a
little outside of cincinnati let's be
honest 30 40 minutes outside
they do a good job there they do it's a
good room it's a good time good staff
and uh
all kinds of fun stuff i'm blanking oh
i'm doing kentucky something in kentucky
lexington not lexington they got to know
what louisville has got just opened yeah
just open that's a cool city so come out
to that never go to kentucky i've never
been there here it's cool yeah i can't
wait love kentucky underrated state
all kinds of good stuff mark
normancomedy.com uh syracuse and also la
jolla
and
oh there's one more
kansas city there it is i pulled it out
of my ass
and uh thank you we love you appreciate
it happy new year praise allah
comedy
[Music]
so
[Music]
you